Is to do it all the time.
The challenge is to sit there basically
because there's so many times when you
just want to flee.
Um,
it's,
it's not the life that I would have
thought.
Um,
it's more difficult in some ways.
The actual act of writing is both more
difficult and more rewarding.
The re you have searched states of
something like ecstasy in your writing,
um,
when it goes well,
when it goes specially well,
and that's not something you can imagine
when you're first starting out.
It certainly wasn't what happened to me
those first few times I wrote poems.
Um,
but then the going on with it is quite
hard.
There was a period when I renounced it
when I was,
oh,
how old was there?
Right after I published my first book,
my life was a mess.
I was separating from my then wife and I
just decided let this life of a poet is
Kelly.
May I have to do something else?
But I couldn't.
Well,
I thought of writing screenplays.
I had a friend who was a director in
Hollywood and I said,
I want to be a director.
And they said,
that's impossible,
but try writing some screenplays.
So I sat that and I started and I found
it very boring.
So I just sat at my desk for a few
months,
really doing nothing but keeping the
same hours I did when I was writing
poetry.
And then I started writing again and I
started writing in a new way and it was
very exciting.
It was actually after my second book,
it's always difficult question for a
power.
What's next?
Um,
you never know whether you're going to
write another poem.
That's one of the,
I mean,
you have faith that you will,
but you never know for sure.
You never know for sure.
If the light will come with the force,
will take it with the music will happen.
So sometimes I think maybe I should try
something else now.
Maybe I should write the novel I never
wrote or something.
Although I really have no gift for that
or no patience for,
but I hope out,
just write some pounds.
I lie.